بعد الانفجار المدويه الذي هز قلب اسطنبول
النابلس شارع الاستقلال في حي تقسيم سارعت
الحكومه التركيه للحديث عن تداعيات الحادث
لا يمكننا ان نقول على وجه اليقين انه
هجوم الارهابي لكن هناك رائحه منه على حد
علمه هناك امراه شاركت في الحادث
المعلومات الاوليه التي قدمها الرئيس
سرعان ما انتشرت لقطات لمراه ببنطال مموه
وحقيبه ظهر كبيره اتفقت روايات الامنيه
على انها من تدور حولها اصابع الاتهام
بدات بعدها تصريحات المسؤولين الاتراك
بالخروج على التوالي لتظهر ان المراه لم
تكن تتحرك بمجهود فرديه بلبات الدائره
المتهمين امام السلطات التركيه اوسع
السلطات التركيه اعلنت انها اعتقلت عشرات
المشتبهي بهم بالضلوعي بالانفجار من بينهم
المراه التي زراعه القنبله لتنشر قوات
الامن صور ولقطات تظهر لحظه اعتقالها كلته
ما نشرت الشرطه التركيه عن هويه وتفاصيل
التحقيق الاولي التي اظهرت ان هذه المراه
سوريه قدمت بصوره غير قانونيه تدعى احلام
البشير وتلقى التدريبا لدى المسلحين
الاكراد
اما وزير الداخليه التركيه سليمان سويلم
فخرجه هو الاخر بتصريحات حول تفجير تقسيم
ذكر خلاله ارقام المعتقلين وصفاتهم ومكان
تدريبهم لكنه لم يذكر المراه منفذه الهجوم
واكتفى بالقاء اللوم على مسلحين اكراد
وحزب العمال الكردستانيه بمسؤوليه الهجوم
الدامي وذكر ان العقل المدبر لهجوم تقسيم
كان من داخل الشمال السوري لكن لم يستبعد
نظريه تورط داعش
بالعمال الكردستاني الارهابيه هي المسؤوله
عن الاعتداء اكتشفنا ان تعليمات الهجوم
جاءت من مدينه كوباني شمال سوريا كما
راينا ان الانتحاري قد مر عبر عفرين
سرعه تحرك تركيا كانت لافته لكن اكثر ما
اثار التساؤلات هو تنوع روايات المسؤولين
الاتراك حول اعتداء اسطنبول في ما لا
تزالوا التحقيقات تجاريه
روان حمزه العربي